[Music]
Yod Vav shkodra yeah do CPR on a
boulevardier pervert a miracle mr.
lavalla mira que dios famous BDSM ha ha
Mazama
yep knocking children
[Music]
staros the second coaches plasma s which
he'll long as a machinist decision he
just melted if you will choose exactly
the best actress gorgeous package which
day-ish mr. couture investable Dogen one
yes Lynette Scavo give me a selfie with
given more significant the generation
resist belief in the Tengu vicodin
ideally to achieve asthma meat or
seafood
my entire life all I've ever wanted to
do is entertain people make people laugh
maybe people smile tell a good story and
I'm very fortunate that this is
currently my platform whether that's
stage of ring or just on the street I'm
I love doing it I love making people
laugh and smile and and taking them to a
different place that makes them a little
happier so this is my first time
performing with a circus so everything
is new to me the travel the living
situation it's been a lot of fun you
live in RV trailers you come to work in
the tent you explore the new city that
you're in I enjoy that life it's fun
my techniques has been compared the data
Bango really is impression walking
assistance
a little more Jackson while out of my
friend I hadn't started not realized
[Music]
clowns in a circus are the human
connection for the audience if there's
someone who's going to reach out and
shake your hand and befriend you at the
circus it's ultimately going to be the
clown so whatever your character is the
goal is that you have to make that
audience connect there's an old phrase
that an old clown once told me is that a
clown falls down so we don't have to and
that's the role that they play and
people laugh as a as a cathartic relief
my mom so much humor is based on
pointing out reality people laugh at the
things that they know are true
I get my inspiration from the characters
and bits and routines from observing
people observing myself reading
traveling I mean everything is grist for
the mill I mean everything is you know
there are things happening constantly
around us all day so I just try to pay
attention to things and sometimes I'll
have an idea that has nothing to do with
what's happening you know in the outside
world it has something to do that's
happening with me on the inside
something more psychological a physical
jokes never get old I mean a verbal
jokes do you know because they're very
topical most of the time and you know
you can hear with verbal jokes today and
it's really really funny and you hear it
you know ten years from now and you go I
don't understand that
I think physical humor is sort of a
timeless art form and that's a great
thing about physical humor you don't
need dialogue so you don't need language
so there are no language barriers or no
cultural barriers a lot of people equate
clowning ultimately with the symbol of
the Red Nosed the misfit clothes the
oversized shoes when you say clown they
good then immediately think circus
whereas when you talk more theater
people think physical comedian
now there is a thing called clown
theater or which very much has been
embraced by someone like Bill Irwin
David shiner a lot of the contemporary
clowns that are coming out now are
specifically working in clown theater
which is a little more metaphoric a
little more symbolic and is really
taking on a life um I saw bill many
years ago when I was living in Paris in
the video some engagement from the New
York Times someone was doing an article
on street artists and she interviewed
means he gave me this video and it was
just fantastic and from that day onward
I always thought I'd like to meet him
and I'd like to work with
I looked at that video and said to
myself that's the best common rule
that's the first guy that has been able
to bring together theater dance and
clowning and create this wonderful
wonderful piece of theater I was doing
Cirque de Soleil here in 1991 and he
came to the show and I saw that he was
in the audience when I invited him
backstage we met and we went out for
lunch the following day and then we were
casting and movie together and we had to
come up with a clown routine for this in
this movie and that's when we both
realized that we had something great to
go
[Music]
tenure won't prosper Osmond is early
semester questioning who believed him
cinnamon Patrice I see don't we only
nice movie enriches well of course Slava
is internationally renowned for himself
no show and the beautiful thing about
him is that he's taken very much what
most people would consider
internationally a Russian tradition of
clothing and he has shared it with
everybody around the world so that in a
way not only has the educated people to
appreciate his style of clown theater
and his style of clowning but at the
same time he has stretched the range of
what is considered a clown but a clown
can work lyrically they can work
metaphorically they could work with
Moloch Lee
[Music]
federal Chaplin stays in maths comedians
nucleation upon my piety McCarron me
Pappy
yeah is federal was in multi-grade me I
mean our Vista girl go first -
technically she got Italian I don't obey
at that biosis to public applause
Palazzo Snapple as Mesa because I had
lagging - my cousins were PW pretium
ekadasi nervous monster basket
yep Adam Eaton interviews Nina
Flavia cada una tormenta many card on
Serena stringini exertion took a swim
each time attention occupy universe
Venus Telugu is a secure relationship in
which all the big home but a move clone
is the concern trust the professor Acura
concentrate such a trend no HHS program
you can't require me 30 inches a
successful clothing said bill Samui
yeah as a performer in theater you're
not normally creating these things new
you are you're taking a script and
bringing it to life as a clown in the
circus you are creating material that
fits you you are creating comedic bits
that highlight what you do well working
in the clowning world it's taught me to
constantly be creative we constantly
have things in my back pocket that I can
do so that if a problem arises or if
during a show something goes wrong
during our material you can then
improvise your way out of it the
question is where can you be employed
and you find that you can work in
theatre whether you're working at a
legitimate play or a musical or sort of
clown the inner piece you can work in
the circus you can work in variety you
can work in the street as you move into
a more intimate performance space
specifically variety even the street the
legitimate theater where the format of
the actual performance allows you more
focus the Performing becomes much more
subtle where you are is very much how do
you connect your your appearance and
your style with where your performance
[Music]
but yes
Tomasz of the 50 creatures chattering
swallow chicken Parvati Rosetta Proctor
and Rotorua's Mosley gradually fluke he
paid me TB nas nas retrieved apostolate
Abdul a tourist abou big lives here
massimo ghini of paprika just and DJ the
bubbles if I had a monogamous trusting
if those Iranian Fortnum probabilities
machine with Panetta
yahwasua beach at the jet relatable spa
course minimally isthmus sustaining at
them clowning has been around for
extremely long time literally dating
back to ancient Egypt comedy and
clowning has always been something has
that has been for the people and for the
longest time it was considered
relatively common so clowning has always
been very much a art form of the street
Shakespeare ultimately came up with the
word clown in trying to describe a
country bumpkin character or a simpler
character who came in who is pure comic
relief for a lot of his plays in England
the clown eventually found its way into
the great English pantomime and was most
put into the forefront by the clown
named Joseph Grimaldi one of the
greatest pantomime clowns ever how the
clowns get involved in the circuit well
now we got to go to France where
Napoleon I was a social commentary and
satire on the one place he didn't do it
with in the circus so English pantomime
clowns come to the French circus and
eventually clowns become the humor they
become the heart
[Music]
the Red Nosed originally was equated
with a drunk over the generations of
clowns and clowning the Red Nosed has
become a symbol of of humanity it has
become a symbol of of emotion in that
regard
once the clown's separated from the
Auguste to the white face which is
symbolic of thoughts whereas the a
goosed clown with the red nose and then
the human face is symbolic of heart or
emotion that circus gets more popular
clowns get more popular the pantomime
world is coming together the circus
reaching a golden age and eventually
where all this pays off a mass
entertainment scale is with vaudeville
and burlesque in America well with the
creation of the motion picture now
suddenly slapstick humour and clowning
becomes international because the
beginning of silent film that was a
glorious heyday for clowning
as I as weasel said in Chapman of
Norwood United meeting we have working
with for the strictest time even that
has moved opinion with the booty month
yes Cyril to the equity guild for the
summer school festival music from the
tgpd affection division and it's a blue
line muniya my general unity I started
very much wanting to know who these
people were you want to do you want to
do big circus props well then you look
to clown greats such as Paul Young and
Felix Adler who back in the 30s and 40s
and Ringling we're doing the giant
circus props you want to learn about
great system of comedy you look to
Buster Keaton and Charlie Chaplin and
Laurel and Hardy even the Marx Brothers
with Three Stooges so you find the
things that you can best emulate
oh yeah McCauley couch idiot Renault ze
most spontaneous want animate attackers
Croatia Slovenia stretchy own fantasy es
que habla de genève Oh own more photos
me Magoo yeah well insularity oriT oh
yeah so delicious tomato ricotta marry
me no sir Amyas Yadav requested which
blissfully is a web of cannot result
wall-e wall-e Tribune is not total Adam
Panama more it's unsanitary old mommy-o
a target a casino in semiconductor
material with tinea totowa extra refills
passivity Madonna's economy yeah with
Roxy Gant movie yeah cooler war machine
by shirt except Nepal no Yosemite
colostomy is reasoning gel suing him you
email travel accessible as a summer day
tissue from illness ministre yellow
diamond aluminum Adama years of the
picking finish Menominee
expedition emotional stress yep
astrology Madonna Maximus very yahushua
Rocco finish at least yeah Buddha Vista
mystical astronomy style he happen cells
New York London Paris Amsterdam
Barcelona grim Moskva
yes Jo pizza keepo schedule
Yemaya brainy si Jana Paris
is my potatoes in vanish world only he
told but he said in 2 Peter presenter
Ramos personal designer on deliver me
unleaded began to make sophistication
ammonia will evolve in email at Miami's
customer from a selection area collected
are others play a Nazi val kilmer
[Music]
whether you pursue a career as a
stand-up comedian whether you pursue a
career as a comic actor or as a
full-fledged three ring circus clown the
goal ultimately of every clown is to
make people laugh or at least to touch
them in some way emotionally
what makes a client was what what makes
clowny powerful is the human heart
what makes climbing power 'fl is that
basically the fundamental groundwork or
the fundamental foundation the Germans
of great were the worshipping the primal
the primal foundation of clowning is
human suffering
you know clowning is about being able to
laugh about the things that hurt or
being able to laugh of other things that
you don't feel that great about the
embarrassing moment feeling humiliated
the loneliness is expel all of it you
know the human condition clowning is
powerful because it deals with the human
condition it's transforming pain until
after especially dr. Susman internally
repeated oh no depression all over
Roboto is loaded it when Academy needle
inches Michigan chakra imagery on ripple
names
IRA's damn he the most oh at Vinny
classy Asia with rods from chick-fil-a
unison assimilation is equal equally
righteousness McCune officiating is a
medium one y media with Institute Arab
people gonna know Naga remove my
designers guilt the current customers
reservoirs in Atlanta over some girl
keeps granite
the public nicki lerczak rather
frequently a Marathi my company but you
gotta say
[Music]
Oh
[Music]